hello and welcome to three scary games
nothing spooky here move on goodbye
[Applause]
hello
and welcome to deadly night not safe for
work mode is it on not safe for work
mode now or
i don't know i'm gonna guess it's now on
not safe for work mode i have no idea no
yeah no not safe for work mode
you have not enabled safer work mode
yeah
oh yeah
this is fine
oh yeah i don't know what that means but
lexi you may have to censor something
aggressively more more censorship
put boobs under it and then censor it
for god's sake censor it
thanks for bringing me here no problem
take care
oh okay bye
well
it is quiet
here there's some wind
hello
nice car a bit dirty though
okay i'm just gonna make up my own story
and assume that i am traveling reporter
from some small town that has come here
to an even smaller town to figure out
what happened when everyone needed to
die
[Laughter]
a vending machine
okay
[Music]
hello mister reception
hotel high motel highway
hmm
that's not a good opener good evening
young lady do you need a room
yes
what brings you here
i'm just passing by i need to catch the
bus in the morning
i see
bus arrives at 8 am do you want me to
give you an hour's notice
that would be perfect thanks
all right
did you come with someone
does it matter
some people come here to have sex is
that your case
you kidding me
no
do you like sex
[Music]
what's wrong with you you sick bastard
wow calm down can you give me
god damn room
yeah you better hurry yeah you better
skedaddle yeah you better get on your
tootsie toes roommate you can pay before
you leave
okay thanks shut up also go to hell
i'm gonna come back there and i'll beat
the crap out of you
now bounce that belly like up look up
look at
him a [ __ ] which is what you are all
right goodbye
later
eat a dick
all right
gonna go to my room now
i'm guessing it might be the one with
the light on
i don't know if i need to investigate
anything
lots of stinky garbage
that is a lot of stinky garbage
anyway
more stinky garbage
why did i just get the feeling that
siren head would be lurking out in those
waiting for me
okay time for a good nights for us to go
investigate why all those people needed
to die
oh ten oh okay room
eight
roommate he did say roommate correct
ah
okay
there we go
perfect and i'm gonna make sure to lock
the door behind me
hello
oh
my god
[Music]
okay enough of that i'm gonna use my key
i can't use mckee
okay but i can go outside okay well then
that it's definitely not locked and i
know i'm definitely not secure well hey
my lights on but you know
the owner is quite weird
is this a mirror i don't like beers
[Music]
hi me i'm looking so good you're in the
bathroom what did i expect i don't know
[Music]
you just checking
oh
i'm amazing oh this is what not safe for
a censor
my channel is gone okay anyway
all right
well now that my channel has been
permanently demonetized i guess
i'll go to bed
i don't trust that that's an actual
mirror
i don't trust that
i don't trust it
well time to hit the old betty bye time
no way am i sleeping with an open
bathroom door
yawn orama boy am i tired and can't wait
to investigate all the murders
oh
wait a minute
hold on a second
uh
oh
oh my god
oh my god
dawg i guess i go
out the front door
why is there no work
what is happening
i know i get it i get that
oh
ah
god
was it a bad dream
i could feel my skin burning
oh
what is that sound
oh
is that recording i'm gonna break that
scumbag's face oh it's ass blasting time
and not the kind you like oh i'm gonna
destroy your face and ass
together by shoving your ass in your
face down your own throat get ready for
a whoopin
get ready to get my fist is gonna go so
far inside of you oh
well that looks bad whatever nothing's
gonna distract me from destroying you
from the outside in
and inside out and sideways too
i'm gonna annihilate you
you
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] must pay in advance and leave
the room before 12 we do not have
telephones in the rooms if only phone is
in the office well i didn't have to pay
in advance that's kind of weird hello
calendar march 27th great
i might need to call someone i don't
know
hello
hey [ __ ] run away i don't like the
sound of that game
oh boy
tissues huh i don't want to think what
he uses these for
well i know
i know what they're for
the guest book
hearing magazines
um
amazing technology
recently recorded vhs well that's not
good
how recently are we talking here
oh boy censor it
oh
he's a dead man
he's a dead man that walks around
he's a dead man
you're a dead man i'm gonna beat the
ever loving [ __ ] out of you what am i
doing here i [ __ ] discovered your
[ __ ] you [ __ ] pervert i will go to
the police and they will lock you up for
the rest of your life
and also i'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
you the police i don't think so you're
gonna stay here until i decide what to
do with you [ __ ] well maybe i'll oh
no you won't it's awfully inconvenient
for you to leave me alone here because
i'm gonna i'm gonna rip you limb from
limb i don't have anything to say about
that
i'm already saying enough but i'm gonna
destroy you
in every way can i use something to
break out here
am i supposed to be able to do something
here i feel like something was supposed
to happen
did something mess up did i break the
game
did i break the game
i'll go save for work mode i guess i got
to restart it because
i think something screwed up i don't
know what but i think something screwed
up
that's not for sale ah perfect perfect
very safe for work extremely safe
really appreciate that thank you very
much thank you
anyway time to kick some ass and
hopefully this didn't break i don't know
it probably did all right
i'm back here again
just dick bag
this douchebag so there must be
something in here
so i must have just been stupid and i
didn't see it i didn't see it there's
got to be something here
oh window is open but i can't reach it
well
whoa bam
easy oh my god was it that simple am i
that big of an idiot am i that stupid
did i not see that before the answer is
all yes
i need to go back to my room and break
those cameras oh do i
it's a little late for that now hello
hi
how are you doing hello another client
another client
anybody there
hello
hmm
time to break some cameras they should
have broken them before but you know
better now than never
what does that sound
oh
[Laughter]
okay
what the hell i need to get out of here
well
justice has been served forget about
breaking the cameras i suppose i'm just
gonna go save my own skin
goodbye
i guess i'm leaving now
goodbye i'm just gonna run
how about i just run how about i leg it
i'm just gonna leg it oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh okay
so being recorded was the least of my
concerns
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i mean all right
then i guess i'm in for a long night
joy
out of the frying pan into the fire
oh and that was just a demo
well that's the end of the story for
that lady she's uh having a bad time not
bad you know uh it was a little bit slow
there could have used like a prompt like
i gotta get out of here i it's just like
there was nothing there was no urgency
of like oh he's coming back it was just
like uh nothing maybe i'm stupid i might
be a little stupid but also that could
have been a bit more clear but otherwise
pretty good i always like love the ps1
aesthetics it's nice it's simplistic
it's a little spooky sometimes but not
bad
moving on
all right welcome to midnight snack you
get hungry you wake up in the middle of
the night your stomach's gurgling or is
that a demon in your gloves no it's your
stomach go down to the kitchen you get a
snack what do you find
yeah most food had to die for you to eat
it so you find food which is technically
death you eat it then you turn around
what do you see
demons
[Music]
like a demon crunch cereal i don't know
i'm sick of this bit i'm going to play
the game
oh freaking hungry man damn i'm hungry
time for my what am i looking at
i saw something there
you can't tell me i didn't see something
there because i definitely saw something
there
hello
huh interesting
all right i guess i go straight down for
my midnight snack then
is that me ripping ass or is the
staircase ripping ass
oh that's comforting
oh yeah that's what we want to see
oh that's what we want to see
my god it's foggy out
i love putting plants on my floor
directly
oh hi
who the frick are you
all right you [ __ ] i thought you were
just a silly little billy
i thought it was going to be like a jump
scare i didn't know that was actually
something that could kill me which is
probably what the instinct should be
when you find a a pig monster in your
kitchen
however
i didn't expect it to actually kill me
so what do i do about that
what do i do about you
oh
is it gone
oh a bonanza
what am i looking at i eat it
yuma rama
now can i get a different snack or is
this what i have to eat well time to pop
her in the old mackerel lava
what am i eating it or what
am i watching tv when i eat it
i'll eat here i don't want to mess up my
room
you're right
i'm going to eat
okay got some fuel in the tank ready to
bed again now
i'm gonna bed so hard i'm gonna bed so
good
oh my god
i'm gonna leave that on
i'm gonna leave that on i can't leave
the light on can't i
oh
oh
oh i'm so heavy oh god these stairs
they're tough to climb oh my god
[Music]
what
what happened
what what did you put in my chicken
if that was chicken
kind of looked like red meat but with
chicken bones and shapes
i don't know i don't want to know i know
what i do i don't want to know
i don't want to know i don't want to
know i don't want to know i don't want
to know i'm moving forward i think i
don't know
i don't want to know i don't want to
know
i don't want to know
i don't want to know i will not turn
around
oh my god i don't know the code what do
you think what you mean i know the code
how do i know the code what's the code
what is what is the code what do you
mean code code my ass code my ass
what code where did you guys see a code
did anybody see a code was there any
kind of code written anywhere around
did anybody notice code ah
i didn't forget your smartphone problems
we'll fix it for you the wi-fi password
is six three blank four okay so it's six
three something four all right i got it
i see something i see something i see
something okay six three something four
six
three
where am i where am i
i fell into the mystery flush pit where
am i
oh it was
just a bad dream with my
father
i don't know what that means anyway that
was not bad one of the things that i
really liked about that was the kind of
the mechanic of like you turn the light
off turn the light on and then a monster
appears and doesn't appear i did like
that i feel like you could have done
more with that but also just as far as
like a small little itty bitty game goes
i did like that i got a spook out of it
and that's all i really unders like won
out of these games so not bad not bad
moving on
welcome to never
open
the door
which is a concept that all of you
should be very
familiar with
anyway i hate that i i hate i hate that
oh what a hectic day it was a good it
was but i slept good i wish i could
sleep for a few more hours but i have to
finish shifting
by luck i got hands on this spectacular
house comfortably within my budget
marvelous homes and such a low price
it's astounding
232a i just shout random facts out loud
whenever i'm walking around my own home
[Music]
i hate you
and here i go in my beautiful home that
i've afforded on my moderate middle
class income
ah
[Music]
well time to go shift
i don't exactly know what you mean by
you have
where the sound coming from did somebody
break into my beautiful new home that i
bought at a reasonable price
hello
oh
i'm back did i sleep on my laptop
seems like i did hey who's here i heard
someone walking did someone break into
my home
did somebody
break into my home i should check the
main gate my god your house has a main
gate
this is a nice house at an affordable
price
marvelous astounding
i question the artwork a little bit
but you did get it for an affordable
price the door is locked i think it was
just my imagination i should do a quick
check in the never mind
i'm done with that thought i'm
overthinking everything
not that i'm overthinking everything but
i'm over the concept of thinking in
general
i just don't like doing it
why is there a piece of paper here
upstairs working still in progress we
will recommend you avoid going upstairs
because the lights are yet to be fixed
and some furniture is still to be shift
what is shift
what do you mean shift
i can't exit it
these words bouncing around my nog
get out of my face
get out of my face help oh i had to
click on the thing again
well that don't look good
time to go check the living room whatev
wherever that is
where's my living room
this door is locked you don't know tents
this is the kitchen
man i really bounce when i walk
this is bathroom
this nod living room
i don't know where living room is
oh was it right here am i dumb
nope
ah
interesting living room
nothing big tv
i think i have more money than i'm
letting on
i'm in my bookshelf
now time to pop a squad and check out
some of the beautiful
channels on my giant tv
what where does this book and candle
from
i don't know
where's this walking song coming from
who walking
[Music]
that's probably fine
someone in bathroom
someone in bathroom
someone upstair
[Music]
do i go upstairs now
is that what i
do hello
sound is coming from my bedroom i think
someone is there someone better not be
there
i'll kill you i'll murder you oh
what the f
what the [ __ ]
this book again am i dreaming or what
so dramatic i will never oh there was
something to read on the other one i
didn't even know that i will never
forgive her how stupid i was i bought
this exquisite house for her and she is
marrying someone else how could she damn
she spoiled everything with her
buffoonery i'll not let her go like that
she belongs to me
let me go read the other one i'm sure
it'll be worth it
i'm sure
who is at the door about this huge
mansion to start my new life again with
the love
i yacht i'll finish shifting
i'll finish shifting as soon as possible
because i have a surprise a yacht with
this beautiful house as our wedding gift
yeah
i'm so excited
good things take time
who is at the door
i'm coming
i'm coming i don't feel good should i
open the door absolutely
100 hold on
wow wow i'm falling in love with this
exquisite house it's so big and
comfortable i would love this i have
bought her a beautiful ring a splendid
ring this ravishing house what a perfect
combination to propose to the girl of my
dreams i hope she says yes why would you
buy
a house before even talking to this
person
a yacht is that you my love
hello
and i need a better fence who is she i
don't feel good i should lock the door
and call the police
what what happened did you see something
did you see something that i did not
because i did not see anything
telephone is in the kitchen
oh i gotta call the police
i gotta go
let's move
let's go
faster
there's no sprint
or take your time i guess ah who's in a
hurry nobody that's who not me that's
for sure where's the telephone i
remember i told them to keep the
telephone in my kitchen
who is them
the book of dark magic perfect my
grandmother used this book to control
and manipulate people i will use the
magic in this book to make her fall for
me all
over again i remember she used to make
animal sacrifice in his agreement
between a human and the devil at that
time i see all this stuff as
superstition
i remember back in the day when grandma
was sliced in open goats and chopping
open pigs and spewing the blood all over
me i laughed and laughed and laughed and
laughed and laughed and laughed and
laughed
oh nonsense utter nonsense anyway
where's my phone
uh oh
okay find the key in the washroom to
unlock the door check the main electric
connection in the basement
oh okay oh you got it pal
i don't know why the key is in the
washroom
nabbed it
time to go to the basement can't wait
eager like a beaver thrilled beyond
belief
am i looking at the door is it hello oh
this is not the basement
where is this where am i
telephone is dead oh
my basement
basement
bird a bubble basement
all right i'm going to go to the
basement
it's kind of spooky in my bubble of a
basement
i don't know why my basement is lined
with candles seems like a fire hazard
hello
[Music]
okay
okay
okay
whole circuit
baby
baby in my basement what are you doing
there bubba baby oh my god
hi baby
okay i don't like you i don't like you
what did you say i i wasn't paying
attention because of the baby well maybe
i should just abandon ship and get out
of here
i'm beginning to think like that might
be the good idea
hi bubba baby
i'm gonna leave now i don't know if
there was something i was supposed to do
down there was there something i was
supposed to do down there
no i think there was something i was
supposed to do down there
oh here hi hello hi
oh wow oh this is a different part of my
basement
oh interesting
i was finding difficulty in operating
this book alone so i called my
grandmother's soul ha ha evil it is
grandmother asked me if she could
permanently reside
inside the doll
well
i said yes of course i said yes
of course
why would i not why is there a garden
down here why you have plants down here
what's with the scrolls logs
this is weird
i don't know why any of this is here
okay goodbye now
oh god
[Music]
i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go search the torch in the
first floor
will do that
i will do exactly that it's gotta be
somewhere it's in the first floor
i guess the music's over now
kinda quiet
of quiet around here
i don't see a torch i don't have a phone
with a flashlight
living room there was two bookshelves i
bet no yes no torch
oh god oh no
i where in the hell would there be a
torch
and i know you mean flashlight i know
you mean that i know that's what you
mean i don't know where a torch would be
what is with these buttons
what's with this dildo-esque coat hanger
what's with any of this
oh no guys it wants me to find a torch i
don't know where the torch is i can't
see [ __ ] and
i don't even know if i'm pressing the
right button to
activate it i've been clicking but i
remembered that you know sometimes
opening a door takes the f button
uh
i don't think it would be up there would
it it said first floor it said in the
first floor
i know they're probably using google
translate but i doubt they would get
first mixed up with second
okay it's gotta be up these stairs it's
gotta be upstairsy they gotta mean like
the first floor off of the main level
there's got la
that must be what it means you know
that must be right
isn't it
hello
there's nothing else right
okay it definitely is up here okay i'm
not stupid
i'm not stupid
i'm not stupid hello
[Music]
well that's fun
i can't see anything
oh
is that a torch
how do i turn it on
how do i
torch
oh leave this home alone i'm trying to
figure out how to turn on my torch
pressing all the buttons i definitely
picked it up right did i get batteries
for it is that was that what oh i just
picked up batteries for it
oh i see
ah
what a lovely home
what a lovely beautiful wealthy home
anyone would be a fool not to accept a
proposal from someone who owns a home
like this
what a home
she helped me kill a yacht's boyfriend
and that is the cost for cheating on me
where will she go now darkheart is so
much fun i'll kill i got two if she
denies me this time
this is a healthy relationship oh hello
nice balcony okay well i'm out of here
i'll see you around crazy soul of the
person who built this house for ayotte
ah this makes sense
sure
leave this home alone leave this home
alone
leave it alone i'm not messing with it i
promise oh
hi wait a yacht how did you get in my
house giant lady
[Music]
how did you come back
you come back here bear come back here
ah someone's rude and undid my seats
oh there's another book on the table all
right giant lady this better be your
phone number the doll the doll it is
changing and moving by itself it's
killing people last night it asked me to
sacrifice seven souls why would grandma
do this this is definitely not her it's
something more evil i don't know your
grandma was like spinning dead animals
over her head with their blood and guts
spewing all over the place
i don't think your grandma was exactly
nice
do i run do i run
what the hell did my eyes just witness
what unfolded before my vision
what the hell
[Music]
what was that
what what happened
that lady disintegrated before my eyes
and oh hi hi babies
hey babies
pick up the cassette and play it on the
tv i don't think my tv is that kind of
bad technology
i don't think it's like that i think
it's modern
i think it's a bit more modern than that
uh oh great good oh good
oh
ah good oh good great good
am i supposed to be watching this did i
need to be watch this did i did i have
to watch this is this something wasn't i
supposed to be exiting the house
wasn't that my objective excuse me
babies i got places to be
excuse me
i gotta get out of here i gotta go
to run out into the woods i guess not
never mind i'm gonna stay i changed my
mind decided i was gonna stay
oh is it over now
[Music]
oh my god oh hey hi
hi how are you doing hey what's up you
okay hey i know i know i know it's okay
hey hey hey it's all right it's all
right you're gonna
[Music]
she's gone
well
this has been
lovely
this has been a delight
this has been just
divine
the plant is floating
hey
[Music]
hi
[Applause]
okay
very impressive with the way that plan
floated
very impressive
but
the phone is working
i should pick it up before it's dead
again
that's how phones work
great
good where was this phone
phone
is this the phone
phone
hello hello
can you find me
can you find me
i'm here
behind you look okay
behind you i'm looking
i'm behind you i'm looking i am right
behind you i'm
don't be scared
i just want to play a game with you okay
hey
don't you run away
please stay
stay with me
if you don't come play with me
and we will kill you
okay
that's a fair trade
instrument i went up the water spout
down came the rain that was spider out
in the sun and dried up all the rain
swimming spider went out the spot again
[Music]
i thought you were gonna go again all
right well it's dead again
i guess i'll be on my way thank you very
much for that i'm gonna go back to bed
now time to hit the old dusty trail back
to bed
okay nope
all right so that was fun do i have any
other uh
things to do
leave the house as soon as possible hey
good idea
good i oh
oh that's not good
right
later dude
i'm gonna leave the house you know i'm
just gonna ignore that i had an
objective to leave the house as soon as
possible
and i'm gonna do that i'm just gonna
leave the house
as soon as possible
i'm leaving the house now
ah
thank goodness
[Music]
thank goodness it's all over now
oh no
an army of giant women has come for me
oh no who are they what do they want
from me
if it cuts it bleeds if i throw it it
returns so i gave the doll to the church
oh if i cut it but then the last night
someone kept knocking at the door and
when i opened it it was the doll it
wants the seventh soul no matter how
hard i try i can't get rid of it oh one
two three four five six
seven well there's seven of you
you have your seven souls
get away from me
what do you want
go away
get off my lawn screw you
well i guess i'm not leaving
oh
[Music]
i somehow sacrificed six souls for it
but i can no longer kill more people the
police is suspecting me but luckily i'm
in custody now nothing can give me here
oh no but the doll out there is still
looking for the seventh soul who won't
leave without taking my soul and i know
i won't stop even after that if you're
reading this run
run for your life
okay hey
i see you there
i see you so how do i run run for my
life
well i'm a little confused my head is
hurting by this voice i can't take this
any longer help me anyone i am innocent
please don't kill me
oh i don't know if you're so innocent
you thought you
you thought you could buy a house you
thought you could be a homeowner
are you ayat are you uh
you uh yeah
listen sorry about your boyfriend but i
heard you're single
oh
where am i was it all the dream
oh boy thank god it was a nightmare
relief i slept while watching the news
channel
ah
that dream chilled my veins thankfully
it was all just a dream
new york is facing big problems in
traffic it feels so real i should make a
cup of coffee
oh no
what a dude
okay so as clunky
as
like low
fidelity as it was i had a good time
with that i really did mostly just
because i was poking fun at it but
honestly
i legitimately didn't have a bad time
with that i
i had a pretty good time i don't know
why that's very strange but i i enjoyed
that and i can't tell you why i don't
know it's good
so that was three scary games
i guess this whole video was
all
just a dream
have a good night
bye-bye
[Music]
you